How to be less afraid of death.
I have a better suggestion.
You should be more afraid
of not living properly.
I don't know if you can
be less afraid of death.
Exactly.
But I think that here's a hypothesis
and this is a Socratic hypothesis.
I write about this in
my book too by the way.
Um,
maybe if you live your life thoroughly,
thoroughly,
right,
you take use of the advantages,
make use of the advantages
that are put in front of you.
Make use of your talents.
Say Yes to things.
Tell the truth,
like stand up and get at it.
I'm assuming that you can do that,
you know,
cause some people are
very ill and hurt and,
but assuming you can do that,
I think the only way to combat
fear of death is to live fully.
And I think that that might actually work.
I kind of wonder,
I've talked about this with my father too.
He was getting pretty old.
You know,
I've asked him if,
for example,
if he could be transformed
back into an 18 year old,
knowing what he knows now,
would he do it?
And he was ambivalent about that.
You know,
he didn't say no,
but he didn't say yes.
And we talked about this idea
that if you lived your life fully,
you know,
maybe that would be good enough because,
I loved having kids,
but I don't feel that I
would have kids again.
You know,
because in some sense
I've already done that.
And so maybe there's a set number of
adventures that you have to go on in your
life.
Let's say you have to be buried,
you have to have kids,
you have to have a career,
you have to have friends,
you have to have something useful to
do with your time outside of work.
All those are all things that are
covered in the future authoring program.
By the way.
Maybe if you do all those,
it's like,
that's good enough.
You've had your life and,
and that's enough.
I mean,
I don't know,
10 years ago I thought,
you know,
if I could extend my life radically,
then I would,
and I'm not so sure
about that now that I'm,
I'm 55 you know,
I'm getting older.
I kind of have a suspicion
that you might come to an end,
you know?
That's what it looks like.
I mean,
I don't want that to be soon,
but
maybe you exhaust yourself in your life,
you know?
Maybe you can so that there's
nothing left of you really.